[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous trouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le très grand plaisir
de recevoir Olivier certain c'est un
journaliste il est versaillais et il est
l'initiateur d'un salon qui s'appelle
écrire à Versailles Olivier certain
bonjour bonjour Véronique merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation l'actualité
brûlante pour vous n'est ce pas car le
salon approche c'est le samedi 3 juin
mais c'est aussi un événement récurrent
et ça fait cinq ans que ça existe voilà
et ça se passe à Versailles on va y
revenir après en détail moi pour le pour
l'instant j'ai envie d'un peu mieux vous
connaître connaître un peu votre
parcours donc vous êtes journaliste mais
encore mais encore en fait je suis
journaliste depuis
40 ans voilà maintenant
j'ai travaillé dans le groupe Lagardère
j'ai travaillé à match voici et entrevue
un magazine un petit peu sulfureux et et
puis en fait je m'occupais aussi des
enfin des réseaux sociaux des de la
vidéo etc etc oui pour les magazines et
donc en fait
lorsque il a fallu un certain moment que
je change de de
voix puisque j'ai simplement été viré
je j'ai créé un blog avec le
savoir-faire que vous aviez en fait j'ai
travaillé avec j'ai travaillé avec avec
Thierry Ardisson et donc j'avais un
certain savoir
donc vous avez tiré parti de toutes ces
expériences et vous avez créé un premier
blog qui s'appelle instant V d'accord
qui existe toujours qui existe toujours
et V pour pour Versailles V comme comme
vidéo d'accord
ça consiste à interviewer des gens ou
des gens variés des gens de la culture
ont des faire des commerçants qui nous
ont parlé de de
leur vie de leur de leur métier de leur
savoir-faire de leur passion et ma femme
me dit mais tu rencontres toujours des
enfin tu dis toujours que tu rencontres
des belles personnes oui oui parce que
ce sont des gens qui sont ben voilà qui
me racontent leur passion et puis
forcément
voilà ça se il y a le petit transmet
grâce à votre micro et à votre écoute et
puis j'imagine que les belles personnes
voulaient vous les repérez
je crois beaucoup à la vie locale en
fait je crois beaucoup lorsqu'on
rencontre des gens on les rencontre dans
les cafés
évidemment là pendant pendant la
pandémie c'était un petit peu plus
compliqué mais
voilà on a enfin j'ai une interview des
gens variés variés ça vous intéresse et
qui m'intéresse je fouille un peu dans
leur vie
et alors du coup ce blog il est toujours
d'actualité il est toujours d'actualité
on continue il y a sur la chaîne youtube
il y a pas mal
d'interviews avec avec mon ami
Christophe Rogery avec oui et puis
parfois il y a Stéphanie Herter qui
intervient ou alors Véronique les
vichyman enfin voilà c'est c'est ce sont
des c'est tout un blog là qui parle de
la ville locale et on met en valeur que
ça soit le maire que ça soit des
écrivains
ou alors ou alors oui c'est ça ou alors
des commerçants d'accord vous avez
compris parfait alors dites moi là on va
parler maintenant plus précisément de ce
fameux salon qui s'appelle écrire à
Versailles qui a lieu depuis 5 ans
maintenant alors comment vous est venu
l'idée de parce que à Versailles on a le
salon histoire de lire exactement donc
on ne parle plus tellement c'est connu
et qui a remporte un succès énorme et
alors vous vous êtes dit je vais créer
mon propre salon exactement en fait il y
a à Versailles beaucoup d'écrivains et
des voilà et qui ne sont pas
voilà et qui ont voulu venir dans le
dans ce dans ce salon qui a lieu donc en
juin et qui n'est pas en concurrence
avec avec le salon
histoire de lire
exactement mais ce sont des ce sont des
yvelinois que de vraiment de la de
l'approche région enfin voilà
on exactement c'est pas de l'entre-soi
c'est simplement des gens voilà qui
veulent nous rencontrer et qui nous
connaissent et puis comme on a eu une
bonne réputation voilà et c'est très
sympa parce que ça se fait dans le
quartier des antiquaires dans ce dans ce
petit quartier ou ses nouveaux cette
année c'est chaque année c'est chaque
année toujours au même endroit dans le
quartier des antiquaires et ça a du sens
parce que le quartier de l'antiquaire il
y a pas mal d'abord c'est un lieu c'est
un lieu magique c'est très sympa et puis
deuxième chose c'est très joli et il y a
des oeuvres d'art et donc
exactement et et nous on ira il y aura
36 36 seulement 36 on est on n'a pas 36
auteurs
il a refusé on a refusé on a pris
vraiment des gens vraiment divers voilà
ce que je voulais vous la question que
je me pose c'est c'est pas très gentil
ce que je veux dire mais c'est pas parce
qu'on a qu'on a habite Versailles où ils
alentours et qu'on écrit maintenant avec
l'autoédition tout le monde peut écrire
et dire tiens j'ai créé un livre bah
voilà il est là il y a aucune censure
rien du tout du coup vous comment vous
faites pour sélectionner les auteurs
parce que j'imagine que oui
avec avec Cyria Benoît avec François
l'écuyer et puis la présidence
Stéphanie Herter en fait on lit on lit
vous recevez les manuscrits exactement
le livre et puis on juge si ça
correspond un petit peu à notre à notre
à ce qu'on à ce qu'on veut mais par
contre c'est quoi son quoi
en fait on fait en sorte que
ça soit quand même assez assez
suffisamment bien écrit et que ça
correspondent aussi à des
à des valeurs aussi sociales qui ne fait
qu'il ne correspondent aussi
et puis mais par contre ce qui est
intéressant maintenant c'est vrai que on
met en valeur des gens qui n'ont qui
n'ont jamais publié c'est leur premier
roman c'est de l'auto-édition c'est de
l'auto-édition il y a la il y a 30
auteurs qui sont auto-édités et 6 qui
sont publiés par la voix classique non
pardon alors donc
qui est autour édité et la moitié qui
est
exactement et on travaille avec la
librairie la suite qui se trouve à côté
et qui vient de s'installer rue du
bagage comment vous travaillez ensemble
c'est à dire en fait qui a commandé
auprès de leur
[Musique]
des maisons d'édition et voilà très bien
et alors ça dure toute la journée alors
ça dure de 11 heures jusqu'à 19h
à 19h il y aura il y aura un concert il
y aura une équipe il y aura une personne
qui s'appelle
Lucia mamos qui sera là il y a Martine
c'est elle qui chante voilà il y a
marqué de griffon qui a un artiste local
qui fait des tableaux
il va vous péter un petit peu à la benne
en fait il écrit dans toutes les dans
toutes la ville et là il va faire des
offres pour nous dans tout le quartier
et j'aime bien parce que c'est très
c'est très ouvert voilà
c'est du carton il fait ça avec du
papier noir c'est des lettrages blanc
sur noir et avec l'écriture encore une
fois exactement et il y a Lucie durivoir
qui est qui est la lauréate parce que ce
que je ne vous ai pas dit est-ce qu'on a
des prix exactement alors
en fait il il y a quelques mois et puis
depuis plusieurs années nous créons des
concours
de nouvelles ou des cons ou des concours
de poésie alors ça c'est indépendamment
du salon c'est un des fondament de salon
pendant la période du covid on a été on
a été assez présent comme ça et puis en
fait
il y a pas mal de gens qui nous ont
envoyé des textes il fallait 10.000
signes voilà et par exemple
ce livre on a on a pu on a pu l'écrire
là on a pu l'éditer il y a quelques mois
et puis la gagnante va présenter son
livre enfin son texte une nouvelle salle
ça recueille de nouvelles avec ces
auteurs ah d'accord avec 16 auteurs et
puis en fait le sujet c'était Versailles
fantastique
parler un petit peu de tout ce qui est
versaillé va un petit peu le un petit
peu le fantastique
voilà qu'on trouve au château qu'on
trouve voilà et c'est assez passionnant
c'est passionnant c'est passionnant
parce que ce sont des gens qui n'ont qui
n'ont jamais écrit et qui se mettent
grâce à nous qui se lancent qui se lance
voilà voilà il se lâche
des des comment dire des carrières
peut-être des des vocations qui
exactement éclore exactement et vous
leur donnez le support exactement ça
c'est beau et pour la première fois ils
sont édités ils peuvent après aller plus
loin et puis
j'étais édité et c'est très sympa
si on veut participer comment savoir
pour participer à un concours de
nouvelles vous en faites régulièrement
nous en faisons régulièrement on en fait
là tous les tous les tous les trimestres
là pour Noël on va faire
si avec avec un thème différent
à écrire à Versailles il y a le site
qui existe et il y a notre contact et
puis ça se fait ça se fait tout seul ça
on travaille beaucoup aussi avec les
réseaux sociaux on est très présent il y
a une chose aussi qu'il faut dire c'est
que on travaille aussi avec avec les
commerçants les commerçants
de Versailles pour nous c'est très
important parce que on ne veut pas avoir
de la culture hors sol on n'est pas
sponsorisé par la ville ou autre ce sont
les commerçants qui nous aident donc il
y a c'est très budget donc on est ça
nous ne sommes pas très riches mais en
même temps on voit que enfin que
Gariguette que enfin que pas mal de de
de commerçant nous aide parce que ce
sont des gens qui nous ont appris tu
fais qui nous apprécient et ils savent
que les gens qui viennent enfin qui
lisent ou qui ou qui écrivent viennent
acheter chez eux c'est du local c'est du
local ça a du sens
et vous avez l'impression que la
population Versailles est très comment
vous la ressentez par rapport à cette
culture écrite en fait
dans la ville et puis dans les alentours
il y a beaucoup
d'amoureux de la lecture de la de la
littérature hier soir j'étais avec un
voisin qui me dit bah oui lorsque je
lorsque je prends le train jusqu'à la
défense j'ai mon livre de Balzac je suis
en train de dire Balzac et c'est vrai
que la belle écriture voilà et c'est
vrai qu'à Versailles lorsqu'on sait que
Proust
Proust il a
il y a tout un tas de enfin d'écrivains
et
d'écrivain ancien et puis il y a il y a
des écrivains vraiment actuel alors on a
envie de parler de qui Christine de
Mazères par exemple qui a déjà été deux
livres c'est
effectivement
tout ça long bien sûr pour présenter ces
deux livres
Bastien c'est un gars c'est assez
passionnant parce qu'il est
au monde de
le monde de l'histoire je sais plus
exactement le nom
nous avons aussi François kasbi Sophie
Loiseau et l'ennemasse long enfin voilà
je pourrais je pourrais aller de le très
loin mais Camille Pascal alors Camille
Pascal
ne sera pas là
en fait c'est son anniversaire et le 3
il m'a dit je suis désolé Olivier je
pourrais pas venir
exactement voilà et puis il y aura Cotis
de Huchet qui est qui qui ne gêne
une jeune écrit zen voilà c'est ça elle
sera là et puis nous avons aussi
Céline Girouard qui qui une dame
aussi exceptionnel et elle s'occupait de
la médiathèque de Viroflay elle est elle
donne des des elle a des ateliers
d'écriture avec d'autres personnes voilà
et donc voilà c'est vraiment
offert de belles rencontres exactement
alors justement on n'a pas fini il y a
un prix mais il existe un prix de ce
salon ou pas non d'accord
c'est vrai que là pour notre pour nous
concours d'écriture on fait des prix là
pour voilà non
c'est très divers donc on parle de santé
on parle histoire on parle fiction il y
a aussi des il y a le tailleur qui va
nous parler des cafés et des et des
bistrots parisiens et de Versailles
c'est vraiment varié et
sous forme donc il y aura des
conférences bien sûr et puis ce qui est
important c'est qu'il y a aussi de
l'écriture enfin pas la jeunesse BD
exactement
pour cette belle initiative qui existe
depuis déjà 5 ans qui est donc ouverte à
tous les écrivains en herbe ou pas et de
Versailles et des alentours merci alors
on fait le point de l'année prochaine
d'accord bon salon merci beaucoup à très
vite Olivier merci merci de nous avoir
suivis à très bientôt
[Musique]